[Música]
hace unos 14 años cuando comencé a dar
clases me topé con una realidad de la
cual no había sido consciente no porque
no existiera
sino porque no me había llamado la
atención
los primeros niveles en los cuales yo
empecé a dar clases fue el de
preparatoria y el de secundaria
para quienes sean profesores profesoras
y han dado clases en esos niveles son
tan divinos
uno aprende tanto de ellos mucho aprende
uno de ellos
aprende aún no a tener retos e ir más
allá
los alumnos siempre le están poniendo a
unos retos y dentro de estas cosas que
yo me di cuenta en este nivel donde yo
empecé a prepa y secundaria
fue a darme cuenta que había una
carencia muy fuerte en tres aspectos muy
básicos del ser humano que son los
pensamientos críticos analítico y lógico
me topaba con alumnos los cuales no eran
capaces de expresar lo que sentía ni
analizar lo que decían
ni pensar lo que leía
en este ambiente de la secundaria y
preparatoria poco a poco me fui dando
cuenta de que lo que yo estaba viendo en
ese momento era el síntoma
y yo descubrí que tenía que ir a la raíz
y empecé a investigar y empieza a ver de
qué manera podríamos hacer de que los
alumnos cuando llegaran a esos niveles
pudieran tener un aspecto donde ellos
mismos supieran expresar
sentir creer
a analizar
toda la estructura de lo que ellos son
capaces de hacer
los alumnos tuve la oportunidad de dar
clases en primaria y fue ahí donde me di
cuenta de que es la base de la
estructura de estos tres pensamientos
ahí dije aquí es donde tenemos que estar
para poder hacer que los niños puedan
tener estas estructuras para cuando
lleguen a estos niveles de secundaria
preparatoria de universidad y ya en la
vida profesional sean capaces de tener
una estructura que les dé
una base donde puedan apoyar lo que
ellos son lo que ellos son no lo que
quieren llegar a ser lo que ellos son
los alumnos de primaria también aprenden
mucho uno de ellos pero si bien sé que
también aprende mucho uno de sus
familias
cuiden mucho lo que hacen frente a sus
hijos y les doy un ejemplo en una
ocasión llegó una niña dice profe cuando
yo este grande quiero tener las piernas
peludas como mi mamá para rasurar me
igual que ella
y yo ok hasta ahí llega mi imaginación
y asunto solucionado tú puedes ser lo
que tú quieras ser hija tú puedes tener
lo que tú quieras tener
entonces los niños son muy transparentes
pero en esa transparencia
en esa precisamente transparencia es
donde muchas de las veces nosotros como
adultos trancamos esa espontaneidad del
niño
porque a los niños les decimos sobre
todo cuando tenemos hijos varones les
decimos tú no lloras porque los hombres
no lloran
y a la niña le decimos tan chillona eres
entonces los niños empiezan a tener un
aspecto de que les da miedo expresar lo
que sienten
y al tener miedo de expresar lo que
sienten van creándose hacia el interior
de ellos mismos una estructura una pared
que los protege el exterior
y ahí fue donde yo me di cuenta que el
rezago lector el cual yo empecé a tratar
y me daba cuenta en preparatoria en
secundaria y universidad tenía y venía
desde esta base
desde que nosotros como adultos siempre
menospreciamos lo que el niño siente
si tú te sientes nervioso o si el niño
tiene miedo es un exagerado
pero cuando yo adulto tengo miedo por
favor haga en mi caso tengo miedo
pero el niño no el niño no no tiene
derecho a sentir miedo el niño no tiene
derecho a llorar el niño no tiene
derecho a sentir angustia
porque no vale lo que tú sientes
y empecé yo a investigar de qué manera
podíamos tratar estos aspectos de la
lectura de la comprensión de la lectora
y de todo este aspecto de los
pensamientos crítico analítico y lógico
y me topé con metodologías que callamos
en lo mismo un adulto dirigiendo
fue cuando empecé a descubrir a un ser
que ha estado acompañando al hombre por
muchos años y me refiero al que le dicen
el mejor amigo del hombre el perro
y poco a poco empecé a introducir a los
perros a una estructura a una
metodología que le llamamos círculos
lectores asistidos por perros esta
metodología y esta estructura se empezó
a dar y empecé a descubrir que el niño
puede leer como quiera leer y el perro
no lo va a criticar
saben cuál es una de las cosas más
fundamentales para que el ser humano
siempre tenga una autoestima la no
crítica destructiva
nosotros como humanos como adultos sobre
todo somos muy fuertes al momento de
juzgar las cosas
y los niños se sienten juzgados
el rezago lector que nosotros tratamos
dentro de esta metodología son niños los
cuales han batallado con acoso escolar
con burlas no nomás de sus compañeros
sino también de los propios maestros o
maestras que estamos frente al grupo y
es lo más triste
lo más triste es que a veces nosotros
como adultos somos los que damos el tiro
de gracia en el niño
el perro va a estar ahí para escucharte
para estar con una cara bien atento como
leas como quieras leer y nunca te va a
juzgar
fue cuando empecé a desarrollar a
desarrollar precisamente estos círculos
lectores
y esta metodología a nivel suelo fue una
de las estrategias que nosotros
implementamos
nosotros aprendemos por varias
metodologías y una de ellas es lo
kinestésico kinestésico es que tendemos
a tocar aquello que queremos conocer
digamos y no cuando han ido una tienda y
dicen no tocar que es lo primero que
hacemos tocar y luego le decimos a
nuestro hijo no toques osito estás
tocando yo sí
porque yo soy cuidado si tú no
el aspecto kinestésico es lo que nos
hace humanos
el bebé al nacer se aferra a la madre
y somos de contacto pero
desafortunadamente este contacto lo
hemos perdido
y conforme vamos creciendo hacemos a
nuestros hijos que tengan el menor
contacto con nosotros porque van
madurando
y madurar significa no sentir
y eso es un error
porque la maduración va implícita en el
sentir
en las emociones en el ser
que seamos capaces precisamente cuando
tengamos algo decir me siento así
y que te pregunten y te digan que tienes
y tú digas no sé
es que siento algo pero no sé cómo
expresar lo no sé cómo decirlo
y esto viene precisamente desde la niñez
en esta etapa de los 6 a los 12 años que
es el aspecto más fundamental del
desarrollo del niño la cuestión
emocional
lo que ustedes están viendo aquí en la
foto
son aspectos precisamente donde el niño
se siente tan tranquilo con un perro que
le está leyendo y el perro no lo va a
juzgar
estos aspectos emocionales tienen que
ver mucho con el cortisol
el cortisol es una hormona del estrés y
cuando hay estrés no hay aprendizaje y
ese es el grande error que tenemos
dentro del sistema educativo queremos
que nuestros niños aprendan cuando traen
niveles de cortisol de estrés
muy altos cuando el estrés está muy alto
y el cortisol está alto esta hormona
inhibe los neurotransmisores que tienen
que ver con el aprendizaje
y no dejan aprender porque el cerebro
está en modo peligro
hagan de cuenta que ustedes están en un
acantilado y cualquier empujoncito los
va a tirar y usted no van a decir aquí
aquí en el acantilado voy a aprender
cuántos dos por dos
no tu cuerpo empieza a temblar
tu cuerpo empieza a decir que este para
atrás porque te puedes caer
eso están viviendo nuestros niños
y medimos precisamente empezamos a medir
los niveles de cortisol de los niños que
estaban llevando el programa con
nosotros
y nos dimos cuenta de algo muy padre
esta medición del cortisol se hizo a
través de la saliva
los niños ponían poquita saliva en un
tubo
doctoras investigadoras y alumnas de la
carrera de biotecnología nos apoyaron en
todas las mediciones
y nos pudimos dar cuenta precisamente de
que el cortisol bajaba a través de la
interacción con el perro
pero yo no quería quedarme nada más se
lo visto yo quería llegar a una
conclusión científica y decir que la
terapia asistida por perros tenía
resultados con bases científicas
y esto fue lo que descubrimos
lo azul lo que está en azul
y lo que está en colores grisáceos lo
azul es el nivel de cortisol antes de la
terapia y los colores grises son los
niveles de cortisol después de la
terapia
cuando bajan los niveles de cortisol es
cuando puede haber aprendizaje no antes
porque cuando bajan los niveles de
cortisol empiezan a surgir
neurotransmisores como la dopamina
serotonina y oxitocina que tienen que
ver con el aprendizaje
esos son los resultados que tuvimos
lo rojo es el es el déficil lector al
principio del proyecto
y después estos resultados se dan
precisamente por un aspecto bien
importante
la seguridad que da el perro la
confianza que da el perro ante estas
situaciones
la cuestión emocional
en estos aspectos
no es nada más que el niño
aprenda a leer y le dé ganas de leer
nada más porque si no hay algo de
trasfondo que es lo motivó
los hombres tienen muy coqueta chicas
dijo el zorro también crían gallinas tú
buscas gallinas no busco amigos pero qué
es lo que significa domesticar significa
hacerse amigos para mí tú eres un
chiquillo más entre otros tantos y yo
soy para digo otro zorro entre huila el
de zorros pero si me domésticas los
vamos a necesitar el uno al otro tú
serás único para mí y yo sólo seré para
ti
tenemos aquí a cabo a gabi y a hans
jansen su perro de terapia
lo importante aquí y lo interesante es
que gabo
antes del proyecto antes del programa
gabo era un niño que no podía expresar
su sentir ni siquiera una sola palabra
leer frente a sus compañeros
y este la grandeza de la terapia
asistida por perros
y ahorita a cabo está leyendo frente
ustedes
es la grandeza
y al fin al fin de cuentas los héroes
aquí dentro de nuestro proyecto de
nuestro programa no soy yo no es la
psicóloga no es la que maneja el perro
es el perro y el niño al fin de cuentas
lo que hacen grande a este proyecto
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]